en un creciente signo de frustración la
oficina de la canciller alemana angela
merkel dijo que estaba dispuesta a
repensar el compromiso del país frente
al gasoducto nord stream 2 un proyecto
de 9500 millones de dólares que conecta
a alemania y rusia
la canciller también cree que está mal
descartar a de los filis el tono del
gobierno alemán o supone un giro a su
inquebrantable apoyo previo al oleoducto
un cambio impulsado por la negativa rusa
de cooperar con la investigación sobre
lo que alemania asegura fue el
envenenamiento del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni un duro crítico del presidente
vladimir putin naval y se está
recuperando en un hospital de alemania
tras salir de un coma inducido luego de
entrar en contacto con un veneno de la
época soviética el oleoducto de 2.400 km
duplicaría la capacidad del existente
oleoducto nord stream 1 que une a rusia
con alemania conectando a europa
occidental con las mayores reservas de
gas del mundo alemán es el país que más
importa gas natural y quienes apoyan el
proyecto dicen que proveería a la nación
de una confiable y asequible fuente de
energía sin embargo el presidente donald
trump dijo que apoyaría a mary kelly
y da marcha atrás al proyecto bueno he
sido solidario con eso fui el primero en
darlo a conocer nunca habías escuchado
el norte swing 2 hasta que lo venció no
cuando lo hice dije un minuto estamos
protegiendo a alemania de rusia de
acuerdo pero el oleoducto ya está
completado en un 90% y estaba programado
para empezar a operar a principios del
próximo año los oponentes temen que
podría ser demasiado tarde para bloquear
su terminación ya que el proyecto está
en su última etapa